usop will become a brave warrior of the
sea this cowardly sniper grew up in serb
village when he was young his mother
died of illness while his father yasop a
legendary pirate and member of shanks's
crew was absent usa was considered a
troublemaker in his hometown the village
hated hearing his lies that pirates were
coming pretty much like peter and the
wolf which was both his way of getting
attention as well as the secret hope
that his father would return to him
however kaia his closest friend usually
confined to her beds loved to hear these
stories when the infamous pirate captain
kuro tried to steal kaia's fortune under
the guise of her butler usopp teamed up
with the straw hats to stop the pirates
and save serve village since then usop
has traveled with the straw hats as
their sniper and strangely all the lies
that he has told over time end up
becoming reality despite his incredible
fear he keeps proving his courage
against way stronger foes so it's really
only a matter of time before